und ja wir waren fast am ende vom
waldstück vor michael rimmer erfahren
ging und das gerechnet durchs meer und
mich und noch 2 jetzt hoffe er ist immer
noch drin war im knie und hannover
[Musik]
ich würde einfach mal interessieren wie
wie ist ihr weg in die
kriegsgefangenschaft gewesen so von
anfang 1945 an in kurland ort und unser
unser letzte station
und das sind die drei länder nicht weiß
weil seine genau oben man erstmal zurück
und es ist halt dann immer wieder nicht
nach vorne gegangen immer wieder zurück
und da hatten wir dann einen einsatz und
zwar in kurland und da waren die melder
gema zur front vorgehen zur linie die
melder diesen immer beschossen worden
und da haben wir dann das waldstück
durchkämmen müssen sagt man dadurch
kämen und schauen wo sind da irgendwie
die scharfschützen de wo immer diese
leute die die melder beschießen
etliche erschossen ja und ja wir waren
fast am ende vom räumt stück einfach mal
grimmen ging ja habe mir vorher hingegen
ja sowas noch nichts runde erst mal
schauen sich dann müssen erst mal
schauen was ist die lage
wo sind die scharfschützen und jan os x
und ich waren an der rechten seite da
und schaue mir aber fast die kerosin da
hinten drehen
die haben sie hinein ein loch verschanzt
so dass man die ja nicht gleich um kann
und und der schon gemerkt dass sie da
wieder neugierig bin kämpfer abermals
linkerhand überladen und ausgerechnet
durchs mia und mich und noch 23
er ist immer noch drin war noch im knie
und war in ober verlangen gerade
splitter
ja die schon auch das ist man immer wenn
man nicht immer dann von drin ist ist
man es trotzdem auch wieder nicht sie
sagten sie wären verletzt worden durch
die granatsplitter und sind sie dann
nachdem sie verbunden worden sind direkt
wieder in dieses waldstück um weiter zu
kämpfen
ist das richtig da bin ich immer dazu
wirkungen naja ich bin ja dann ist das
red chris laxere und wir sie wahnsinnig
gern 45 uhr nochmal danach geschickt ins
kurland und von dort hat immer immer
rückwärts in einen moment wo man denkt
jetzt ist man zu hause weil ist verletzt
man hat es geht dadurch vielleicht
langsam heute endlich der klärgas ist
das denkmuster prävention so weit ist
alles stalingrad kaputt und so weiter
man war nicht voller zuversicht
aber das wort ist na ja und da haben wir
nochmal nach liebe und dafür gesorgt
dass heute immer langsam zurück wenn man
schon kriegsendes an und da ist halt
doch da auch die mal gekommen und da sie
dies natürlich cds gesammelt und wir
wurden in ein großes lager war vertrag
verfrachtet und es war ein hohen ein
lager von einer von einem sägewerk das
dann nur zu bekriegt und rot morgens
suppe und rot am studium brot und das
war so die ernährung
da ging es ums nackte überleben
eigentlich nicht viel zu sehen
und da war und da waren wir heute in
verschiedene arbeitsgruppen eingeteilt
worden
und da war ich einmal auch in einer
anderen gruppe die seinem coach aus
kummer
da waren die kartoffelernte war das aber
alles mit der hand darauf wohl keine
maschine die aus gram und und alles
alles nicht da wo er auch wieder mal
zwei wochen hin in cardiff während die
das ist weder hand kommt meine güte alle
aufgesprungen
ja und da wurde ich dann krank es war
dann oktober die ärztin haben wir immer
wieder untersucht wegen fieber und dann
ist das fieber doch einmal weg gegangen
und ich war wieder frei im lager und was
kam dann wieder dazu der pazifist ja ich
muss natürlich wiederum jetzt muss sie
da wieder so unser lang warten
bist du da negativ ist und dann in der
zwischenzeit ist ein tanz bord gegangen
hey du wärst eigentlich doch schwach
kann es doch einmal mit kummer
natürlich warten auch immer wieder kaum
herumkommen
und dann ist dies der der befund
commander kommt sind katrin riedel
ergebnis gut negativ und und am penny
entlassen worden und bin ich auch zu den
ikonen der eu zum transport kommt wenn
er in der gefangenschaft hat einen
irgendwann man erlebens mut verlassen
wird wenn man gar nicht weiß wie es
weitergeht kommt man da jemals aus denkt
man dass man da für immer bleibt nur die
hoffnung stirbt nie aus immer oft immer
wieder dass er mal
wie sie heimkommen aber wann der ersten
vorstellung macher kennen wenn ich das
weiß auch was ist so rückblickend wenn
sie den ganzen krieg und die
kriegsgefangenschaft anschauen was war
ihr schlimmstes erlebnis was sie da
hatten schlimmste immer so wie ja du
stehst du mal dort und da unten
kopfschuss der hangkante vor der nase
das sind nicht angenehm aber mal das ist
einmalig hat jetzt das gewesen was
andere wollen wir darauf wieder
zurückgezogen worden seien und oder oder
andere erleben diese wurst so mitten in
der kälte durch die gegend transportiert
wird wohl alles aber es ist vorbei gang
hat es überlebt denkt man immer land so
denkt schon mal wieder ne schlafstätte
und haben mal wieder dass vor
davos wieder das waldstück siehst du
siehst du wieder wir werden jetzt
momentan da forscht ist und da ist es
ist uns schon vorher im traum und zu
oder du denkst dann das konto wieder
aber ist verfolgte ich nur in dem sinn
dass eine kleine weiterschlafen grund
mehr das ist und du willst eigentlich
gar nicht denn glaube dass das feld hat
einmal und so zu
ich habe noch eine frage ob wenn sie
sich die generation die jüngeren
generation heutzutage so anschauen da
sehen sie menschen die große sorge haben
vor dingen wie klimawandel vor
rechtspopulismus und vielleicht auch
noch vor flüchtlingen und anderen dingen
wenn sie den menschen eine botschaft
senden würde
aus ihrer sicht mit ihrer erfahrung als
sie so alt waren haben sie im krieg
gestanden haben sie gekämpft
was wäre das sagen sie zu denen halb so
schlimm
oder sagen sie zu dem passt schon das
wird schon alles funktionieren oder
sagen sie ihr müsst wirklich aufpassen
was was ist ihre botschaft
da können sie mal sehen wir sind da
draußen gewesen und haben mit dem
teleskop durch die westlichsten so
schlimmes erlebt wie im zweiten
weltkrieg
egal ob es in welcher stelle er gekämpft
hat oder geht gelebt hat das ist
furchtbar gewesen dass ihr euch zum
beispiel nimmt und nicht noch mehr gegen
diese typen da also sich euch zeigt dass
dies nicht so wieder noch mal sowas gibt
aber es man sieht ja es gibt leute die
sind so eingestellt seien mitbringen um
allerletzte frage wenn ihre enkelin oder
ihre urenkelin sie jetzt fragen würden
ob europa wenn ich meine zukunft so sehe
was würdest du sagen kann ich positiv
oder negativ in die zukunft sehen was
würden sie sagen ja wir das sagen schaut
positiv ins leben es gibt immer wieder
licht nicht nur nicht nur dunkel
also wir haben ganz herzlich sei dank
nichts zu tun also der kritik